[Music]
whenever i cook i am like a tornado and
my boyfriend challenged me to cook with
as little dishes as possible and i said
okay so i'll make some dessert and i
ended up doing brownies all in one bowl
which was pretty fantastic if you ask me
if i were making normal brownies i
probably would have melted the butter in
a separate bowl and melted the chocolate
in another bowl and just compiled dishes
on dishes on dishes but with this one
you end up melting the butter and the
chocolate together in the same bowl let
the chocolate and the butter sit fully
for three whole minutes before you even
stir it if you don't you're going to end
up with lumpy chocolate it's not gonna
be fully melted not gonna taste as good
and you really want that thick creamy
smooth chocolate and butter mixture
and then just add the dry ingredients
into it it's easy it's wonderful it's
one dish brownies are a special treat
for me whenever i have my nieces and
nephews over i always make brownies with
them it's kind of our special thing that
we do and it's just a cool moment to
have with some great kids
if you're short on time this is the
recipe for you it not only is really
easy but you're only using one bowl and
you're also saving time on prep because
you don't have to pull out a whole bunch
of bowls and a whole bunch of dishes to
get the mixture together it's just one
bowl there are some really beautiful
shots in this video like the chocolate
stirring so pretty i'm really proud of
this one you guys
it's so good
the only other dish you use is the
baking sheet which you line very nicely
with parchment paper and you lift it out
when the brownies are done and cooled
and it's just
heavenly because that dish is clean yes
one dish i did it
[Music]
when you're baking brownies you always
want to make sure and let them cool
completely before you even touch them
you want to have a brownie that's going
to hold together right you don't want a
disgusting
sloppy mess and i know it's hard to wait
but they are so worth it because they're
going to be that dense chewy
chocolatey texture that you really want
in a brownie and these deliver a hundred
percent another fight in my household is
over who gets the middle piece of the
brownie or who gets the end piece the
piece in the middle is nice and gooey
and chocolatey and the outsides are nice
and crispy and crunchy for those end
piece lovers i'm a middle piece person
and so is my boyfriend but we have to
fight over it to the death and i'm gonna
get you next time buddy
tell me in the comments which piece you
prefer are you an end piece are you a
middle piece are you a corner piece
tells a lot about your personality
[Music]
you